madame la parole est à madame nathalie
kosciusko morizet monsieur le premier
ministre
on nous a déclaré la guerre le mot a
maintenant été utilisées des deux côtés
de l'hémicycle aussi je ne veux pas vous
interroger sur le mot lui-même mais sur
les conséquences que vous en tirez car
on ne fait pas la guerre avec les moyens
de la paix les attentats en france en
tunisie au koweit ont montré notre
vulnérabilité à la menace terroriste
menace terroriste qui trouve ses bases
arrières à l'étranger dans des vastes
zones de non droit nos armées sont
présentes sur ces fronts parfois dans
des conditions très difficiles et nous
voulons tous ensemble rendre ici hommage
mais je veux dire aussi que la volonté
et la bravoure que décrit si bien le
général baré rats dans ses notes de
guerre sur l'opération serval ne
suffisent pas or en dépit de vos
annonces
le sous-investissement et le
sous-équipement persiste et récemment
même encore des décisions ont été prises
qui témoigne d'un manque d'anticipation
par exemple sur les frégates dans le
livre blanc 2013 on annonçait 15
frégates de premier rang il n'y en aura
que 10 pour notre marine sur le charles
de gaulle à l'automne 2016
il sera à quai pendant 20 mois que se
passera-t-il pendant ce temps là pas de
porte avions et pourtant au même moment
vous renoncez semble-t-il à lancer les
études pour un deuxième porte avions et
j'aurais pu aussi parler des drones ou
des hélicoptères de transport lourd qui
manque cruellement à nos troupes en ce
moment au sahel
monsieur le premier ministre bien sûr
tout ça suppose des choix budgétaires
très lourd mais enfin les mots ont un
sens
les mots ont un sens pour nous ils ont
instance pour nos soldats vous avez
utilisé le mot guerre quelles
conséquences entendez vous en tirez la
parole est un monsieur jean-yves la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
madame la députée vous poser une
question légitime car quand
effectivement on parle de guerre et nous
l'avons fait je l'avais fait le 13
janvier en parlant de guerre contre le
terrorisme contre le djihadisme contre
l'islamisme radical
il faut se doter de moyens ses moyens
d'abord pour lutter contre le terrorisme
très directement
ils ont été rappelées de manière très
précise dans un document par ailleurs
distribué par le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve à l'occasion de cette
rencontre avec les présidents des
assemblées les présidents de commission
les présidents des groupes de
l'assemblée et du sénat
ces moyens ils sont considérables il
implique bien sûr nos services
la police les renseignements des moyens
supplémentaires technique
il implique aussi je veux rappeler nos
armées dans le cadre de l'opération
sentinelles ce sont 7000 militaires qui
sont mobilisés aux côtés des gendarmes
et des policiers et qui surveille
ensemble 5000 sites sensibles lieux
cultes écoles services publics
et c'est là un effort nouveau est
considérable à la hauteur bien sûr de
cette menace terroriste moyens bien sûr
pour le ministère de l'intérieur je
viens de le dire mais également pour le
ministère de la justice et ses moyens
nous les assumons dans le cadre de notre
budget du budget 2016
et bien sûr comme ceux qui vont suivre
parce que nous savons que c'est une
priorité et d'ailleurs pour ce qui
concerne la sécurité et nous le savons
notamment avec bernard cazeneuve ou
christiane taubira ce sont des budgets
prioritaire et nous avons augmenté les
moyens en poste et en effectifs
mais les moyens aussi de fonctionnement
pour la police et la gendarmerie pour
lutter contre l'insécurité pour faire
face au terrorisme
et pour ce qui concerne nous armer et le
ministre de la défense et bien sûr vos
dispositions au service des
parlementaires comme il le fait
régulièrement pour revenir sur ces
sujets là mais dans la date
programmation militaire nous avons aussi
tiré les conséquences d'abord dans celle
qui a été votée c'était suite au livre
blanc il y a quelques mois mais encore
il y a quelques semaines
vous l'avez fait avec le ministre de la
défense parce que là aussi il faut
renforcer nos moyens et pas seulement
nos moyens pour l'opération sentinelle
mais également parce que nous
considérons et nous l'avons bien décrit
je crois ensemble au salon du bourget
les moyens qu'il faut notamment en
matière de drôle donc les armées
françaises ont les moyens pour faire
face à cette menace et pour faire face
aussi aux interventions et assumer les
responsabilités qui ont été décidés au
plus haut niveau de l'état par le
président de la république
c'est vrai pour l'opération serval
aujourd'hui 3500 militaires sur la zone
barkan pour la zone du sel c'était vrai
bien sûr pour l'intervention au mali et
c'est vrai aussi pour assumer nos
responsabilités dans le cadre de la
coalition où nous intervenons avec nos
mirages et nos rafales sur l'irak pour
combattre déj sur tous ces sujets là
madame la députée travaillons ensemble
ne polémiquons pas sur ces sujets là
parce que je vous demande d'être
cohérente madame la députée vous ne
pouvez pas demander dans le cadre ne
pouvez pas demander dans le cadre d'un
débat tout à fait légitime elle c'est
l'eau brute réparer le rendez vous 100
milliards d'économies 100 milliards
d'économies supplémentaires de baisses
d'impôts et nous demander en même temps
que tous soient prioritaires que la
sécurité soit prioritaire que la défense
au prioritaire que l'école c'est nous
qui disons sens prioritaire que les
collectivités territoriales sur
prioritaires vous le demander de faire
des économies vous le demander de
renoncer à des réformes aussi
importantes comme celles concernant les
allocations familiales
alors madame la députée c'est bien de
s'intéresser au sujet de défense mais je
vous demande de la cohérence parce que
c'est ce que les français attendent
merci monsieur le premier